the only way to keep my oxygen levels
even in the 80s was to remain on oxygen
and in bed this is a patient
experiencing long covid a term that
describes a wide range of lingering
symptoms that can last anywhere from 4
to 12 weeks or more estimates about the
prevalence of long-covered range
depending on the study and how they
define long-covid but one recent review
found that more than half of
unvaccinated covid19 survivors
experienced long covid for the
vaccinated population another study
found that the percentage dropped to
about 19 percent but as the third year
of the pandemic approaches doctors are
searching for more information about
what long covet is why it happens and
how it can be treated
we know that subscribe ii the virus
which causes cov19
is primarily a a land infection dr patty
centongo and his colleagues from penn
state looked through 57 peer-reviewed
papers to better understand long-covid
but we found that every organ from the
brain
through the cardiac system and the
gastrointestinal system even the skin
all these organs were affected a
patient-led initiative showed people
with long covid display over 205
individual symptoms that affect 10
different organ systems research
pinpointing the exact cause of long
covid is ongoing as is the question of
how different variants like omicron
impact one's likelihood of experiencing
lingering symptoms but scientists are
exploring three main theories about its
source the first is that parts of the
virus are still present in the body and
periodically get reactivated the second
is chronic inflammation which is caused
by leftover inflammatory cells that
affect the organs and cause inflammatory
symptoms like stiffness and fatigue and
the third suggests long covid is an
autoimmune reaction meaning that the
immune system is in overdrive and the
body is producing new harmful molecules
that attack its tissues i think at this
stage it's important to point out that
that all three could be possible dr
david petrino has managed over 2 000
long covet cases many people over
produced inflammatory molecules
during their acute infection and they
did so in a way that was not correlated
with severity of acute infections in
these cases even patients with mild
symptoms could experience something
called a cytokine storm cytokines are
molecules that regulate the body's
inflammatory response but over
production of them can cause damage to
surrounding cells like nerve tissue
nervous
systems that are associated with
the autonomic nervous system such as the
vagus nerve you know it's the longest
nerve in the body it has projections
that touch pretty much everything in the
body and so depending on which branch of
a nerve like the vagus nerve is
being
affected can produce
symptoms that vary from
you know a rash on your skin
all the way through to heart
palpitations or
cognitive issues centango's review found
approximately one in three covet 19
survivors was diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorders one in four with sleep
disorders one in five with depression
and one in eight with post-traumatic
stress disorder that inflammation from
the cytokines can injure the brain or
the neurons
and that can lead to the manifestation
of a neurocognitive outcome with the
wide scope of long-covered symptoms dr
centango says treatment needs to center
the patient so the treatment aspect to
me is developing kind of like a
treatment plan it's kind of one stop
treatment center for kobe 19. this is
the approach at yale medicine's post
covid19 recovery program first patients
are referred and assessed based on their
needs then the necessary doctors are
brought in as much as i would love to
see every patient is exactly like they
really aren't dr denise luchmann singh
is a pulmonologist and is leading the
program at yale she says variability is
the one constant it actually is
interesting because you have to kind of
think of post covert care as a little
bit more of personalized medicine
which we should have probably been doing
anyway in medicine one scenario that
complicates treatment is when patients
report persistent symptoms but show
normal testing it's these patients that
have led yale to take new measures in
search of answers we've started doing a
little bit more invasive testing on
something called our cardiopulmonary
exercise test putting ivs into the large
blood vessels of the neck or into the
arteries while the patients are
exercising some of the findings that we
found in those patients have been
similar to
test results of that particular test in
patients with a history of chronic
fatigue syndrome another finding showed
that while oxygen was reaching the vital
organs once it got there it was not used
normally this could explain why some
patients feel shortness of breath that
was one of the things that led to more
questions well why is this happening is
this something related to
you know antibodies or inflammation or
nerve dysregulation and then the other
question was still well if this happens
in one patient is this what is happening
consistently across the board for every
patient two recent papers bring new
information on who may be more
susceptible to long covid one of them
cites the presence of auto antibodies as
the most prevalent among four potential
risk factors auto antibodies are usually
associated with autoimmune conditions
such as lupus and rheumatoid arthritis
but dr petrino remains cautious and we
need to keep following up on these
things to better understand what's
happening in larger sample sizes so you
know these are certainly things that
should be published and we should
have them at front of mind as we move
forward but they shouldn't be definitive
and i don't think the authors
intended them to be researchers from
both studies said their findings better
inform our understanding of long covid
with a researcher from the cell study
saying the paper's findings will likely
help guide further research although the
science of long covet has evolved big
questions remain about its impact i have
patients who are nurses and firefighters
who will fit who have climbed mountains
and run marathons and they are limited
and i don't think
we understand in society what this is
going to mean for us in a couple years
but i think it's going to have a massive
impact
[Music]